now what the post moderns are going to
be arguing is that we understand there
has been a revolution in all of these
areas over the course of the last
several centuries we think all of that
has come to an end and we need to go
beyond that and then more normatively
most of them will say we think the
modern world has been a mistake
I'm joined by Stephen Hicks Stephen
welcome the show hey appreciate the
invitation and banks very very glad to
have you on
so post-modernism and socialism right
there words thrown around along and yet
I can't define them myself I don't if
you ask me to tell you what are what do
these words mean I couldn't give you a
definitive answer and I don't think many
other people could either so can you
well fair enough yes all of those are
high-level abstractions and we're a
smart species we take huge amounts of
information in about the complicated
world and so it is a process to go
through to - to define any high level of
abstraction now those two are not unique
if you try to define liberalism or
conservatism or in Christianity or
religion or Islam again there are going
to be lots of variations and lots of
things that are being included in those
concepts so you should expect that it
has to be some work right before a
definition arises now to take
post-modernism first the the labeling is
well chosen I didn't originate the term
but if you burst break it down
post-modern right so that means we
understand what post is it comes after
or it's a replacement right of and then
modernism so what do we take modernism
to be then we start to break that one
down well different areas of inquiry
literature history philosophy they often
use labels like that differently so I'm
a philosopher by training and I do
history of philosophy so I am using it
the way philosophers and historians will
use modernism and basically that means
the last five hundred years or so of
history especially in the the Western
world and that makes sense because if
you look at what was going on in the
world 500 years ago
well it's within a generation of
Columbus crossing the ocean and that's a
game-changer on all sorts of dimensions
it is the generation of the high
Renaissance so we have Leonardo da Vinci
Michelangelo Raphael Titian and other
revolutionary artists who are
functioning so the art world is changing
dramatically it's going to be the
century in which Vesalius is publishing
his anatomical works so we have a first
study of how the human body actually
works its Copernicus coming up with the
idea of the Sun being at the center of
the system instead of the earth so
modern physics and astronomy are being
revolutionized it's the century of
actually in the 15 teens Martin Luther
and the beginnings of the Reformation
and the Counter Reformation so it makes
sense that historians and philosophers
were saying you know there's a huge
amount going on in all of these sectors
the world is being upended and so forth
so we're into the modern world we are
global we're doing religion differently
we're doing science differently we are
going to put our going to think about
politics and economics differently and
an art is changing so that's what we
mean by the modern world now what the
post moderns are going to be arguing and
is that we understand there has been a
revolution in all of these areas over
the course of the last several centuries
we think all of that has come to an end
and we need to go beyond that and then
more normatively most of them will say
we think the modern world has been a
mistake or that all of those revolutions
that have occurred have led to negative
disastrous pathological results and so
we need to transform society in in
another
direction now to try to summarize more
quickly what they will typically then
say is the modern world is marked by
capitalism in economics that replaced
feudalism it's been marked by an effort
to have Democratic Republican politics
again replacing feudalism and they're
going to argue that we think both of
those are fundamentally flawed and/or
mistaken so all of the leading post
modernists will be anti-democratic
Republican and that's why we see a lot
of authoritarianism you know that the
worst versions of political correctness
and rather than solving our differences
socially and politically through
voluntary methods you see a dramatic
increase among postmodern friendly
people in adversarial
in your face and of outright
authoritarian types of tactics
there are also to a man and woman
anti-capitalist anti-free market so you
will see all of those criticisms at the
modern economic world is a disaster it
exploits the poor it has dramatic
inequalities all of which are sickly and
so forth the post moderns will argue
that the modern world has also been
marked by high science and high
technology but they will mount an
argument that science and technology the
results are negative the dangers
outweigh or they will be making
arguments that science is just a mail
way of thinking or a white way of
thinking so you'll get racial and gender
attacks on the scientific and
technological project but also you'll
find that the modern world has been
marked by a strong amount of
individualism you know the individual
rights to life liberty pursuit of
happiness pursue your own dream become
an entrepreneur high levels of tolerance
for other people of different political
persuasions different religious
persuasions as well but that
individualism that underlies much of
modernity the postmodern
disagree with that as well that's why
you find the rise of identity politics
and and and the postmoderns want to
organize and see people as members of
groups you're primarily a member of your
racial group or your ethnic group or
your gender group and it's your group
identities that make you who you are
it's not individual choices and so on so
modern world individualism science
technology freedom in markets liberal
democratic politics the postmoderns
reject all of them and want to replace
them with something else so that's a few
minutes on post-modernism how's that
fantastic it doesn't sound like post
modernists agree with much there was a
big list of things yeah yeah yeah the
modern world is this big complicated set
of revolutions on a number of dimensions
and the postmodern czar very
well-educated individuals particularly
in the first generation Michele Foucault
Jacques Derrida Richard Rorty and they
are taking a big-picture perspective on
what's happened in the in the world over
the course of the last 400 years
philosophically historically and
subverting and rejecting all of it in
fundamentals yeah absolutely
so was socialism was that the
differences and the similarities here
yeah well let's start socialism
differently we can make connections to
post-modernism later socialism is a an
ancient philosophical / ethical /
political / economic idea as the name
suggests we prioritize the social over
the individual so you know if we ask
what's the purpose of having social
organizations family teams businesses
political units and so forth right one
basic political answer to that is to say
well it's it's it's for the purposes of
the individuals involved
so we formulate family groups primarily
to nurture individuals so that children
can grow up to pursue their own
individual dreams or we form business
associations where we work together
socially but each of us is pursuing our
own individual careers and so forth we
join in sporting teams and there's a lot
of value to to following a sporting team
as part of a group but primarily were
individuals coming together and and
we're enjoying sports as as individuals
as participants and so forth so what
socialism
wants to do is to say that we should
always prioritize the social over the
individual the group is more important
than the individual and if there's a
tension between what's good for the
group and what's good for the individual
the individual should sacrifice or be
subordinated for the sake of the group
by contrast individuals will say look if
the group is not just working out then
we will just go our own ways social or
our own ways as as individuals so you
know you know an interesting example
might be religion if you're familiar
with say within Christianity the big
split between Catholics and Protestants
so the so is we get over we're Catholics
and we're having some arguments about
what Christianity really means and
ultimately it seems you know you and I
just can't agree on what proper
interpretation of some religious
doctrine it could be the Catholic
position is that you as eye on you and I
as individuals we should be willing to
set aside our individual judgment for
the good of Catholicism as an
institutional religion and that that the
tradition as a whole should take
precedence over my judgment or your
judgment
whereas the Protestants would be more
likely to say all right suppose you and
I are Protestants and we're a member of
the same church and we're having some
arguments about how should we
appropriate or prett Christianity and
we've been back and forth a lot we just
agree on this so what should we do about
that well Protestants are more likely to
say well you really need to do your
thing because the state or soul is your
primarily individual responsibility and
I need to look after my soul so what we
should do is just go our separate way
right you'll go and start your own
church and I'll go and start my own
church and we'll pursue our
individualistic path and associate only
with individuals who in their heart of
hearts agree with what we have there
so that individualism versus socialism
is not only a political economic thing
it's it's a deeper understanding about
whether individuals or the social takes
precedence now when we turn to economic
matters the individualist are more
likely to end up being free-market
capitalists you'll decide for yourself
what your career is going to be what
you're going to make you'll offer it on
the market customers may be interested
you'll negotiate as an individual
particular individual deals and then the
same thing for me as a consumer I'm
going to take responsibility for making
my own decisions about what I'm going to
buy what prices I'm willing to pay how
much I'm going to save and so forth so
we're all autonomous free agents
entering into the market as buyers and
sellers and so markets are going to be
an emergent phenomenon what socialists
are going to argue is that we should not
be functioning as individuals when it
comes to economic matters
we should have society as a whole and
there should be institutions that will
decide for society as a whole
what's going to be made who's going to
get what and how much and each of us as
individuals producers and consumers
should not be making our own decisions
we should be following the decisions
that are made at the society as a whole
level so how's that for two or three
minutes
absolutely yeah it's um it's so
interesting is someone who doesn't delve
massively into politics other than one's
other than one it's forced upon me so
for instance the recent British general
election it's only been a few months
since that happened and you have this
big surgeon
of patriotism for one side or the other
in the Ucayali
I guess there's a little bit more of an
even split at least as numerous parties
that you can vote for in the UK whereas
in America it really kind of it's just
one or the other and words like
post-modernism and socialism get thrown
around as slurs you know you accuse
someone of being a socialist or you
accuse her of being a determine the UK's
a Tory which is a conservative and each
side's mudslinging it the other with
terms which well I'm not actually too
sure what that where Tory comes from
what they're eating ology of that is but
yeah the the the socialism you know it
sounds like a perfectly well thought-out
system which is not just about as you
say not just my economics not just about
political theory but on a much broader
scale - sort of a philosophical position
and yet you can take pretty much any
words like call calling someone a carrot
or you know calling someone like it's
higher or something like that you can
take any word in and start to throw it
around like a slur it's I wonder what
your thoughts are why it's come about
that you socialist why does it have
baggage attached to it right well yes
you're you're absolutely right about how
political debate goes and by the time he
gets to politics and election cycles you
know that in a parliamentary system like
Britain's or like Canada is where I come
from now the election cycle is just a
few months and nobody has time for
careful or nuanced positions in the
give-and-take and emotions running high
so where all of this should be happening
better is in schools and universities in
newspaper columns and and so forth in
the years leading up to elections where
people are discussing these issues in a
more leisurely and hopefully less
emotionless
and emotional is context but yes you're
right though also that all of these
labels have
baggage attached to the method and
that's uh that makes perfect sense
because all of them have a historical
track record and the history matters
absolutely so in our generation anybody
who's thinking seriously about being a
socialist or being an anti socialist
they should recognize that there have
been in the modern world two centuries
now of theory and practice and socialism
and before you make up your mind whether
you're pro or anti socialist you should
know something about that that history
now why I think in Western nations and
increasingly around the world socialism
has a bad aura is that for centuries in
the modern world now we've been
committed
much more to individualism free markets
liberal democracy and so forth and
socialism is opposed to all of those
things and then if you look at the
history of the 20th century the major
experiments in socialism were in the
social in the Soviet Union and that's
the Union of Soviet Socialist Republics
the USSR and that was a 70-year
experiment from 1979 to about 1990 in
trying to have a very authoritarian form
of socialism and the end result of that
was quite brutal millions of people
killed and an additional hundreds of
millions of people over the course of
generations lives impoverished so the
human rights track record and the
economic track record of the Soviet
Union was a disaster and people who know
something about the history then get
worked up about it and say look if in
the concurrent generation you want to
reinstate socialism that's a bad thing
the other major experiments in socialism
in the 20th century were in China
communism is a type of socialism and so
again under Mao Zedong a major
experiment in socialism and again it was
a disaster with millions of people dying
of starvation and millions more killed
for political repression
reasons as well Cuba in the Western
Hemisphere some of the South American
nations African nations other Southeast
Asian Nations there's a long history and
I think quite rightly people who are
anti-socialist are insisting that
socialists now need to confront that
history and be articulate in what they
say in response to that history before
just in any casual way saying hey let's
try socialism again that sounds it
sounds like quite a commitment you know
if that was yeah if someone if someone
said hey this is the this is the track
record of what we're in for
do you do you fancy you go at this I you
know that it doesn't it didn't sound
fantastic
right yes so what what what's then is
interesting though about socialism and
the way it typically has an appeal is
for people who don't know very much
about the history don't know a bunch
about the political theory haven't yet
taken some economics and they're they're
younger people and younger people are
delist ik and what socialism says to
them is we will give a lot of power to
the government but the government will
look after all of society's resources
and we're saying in Britain were in a
quite a prosperous country so there's
enough to go around and the government
will just make sure that everyone is
looked after and it will have smart
people in power and they will make sure
that the argue the economy runs in in a
proper direction and for for naive
people I can understand you know that
that sounds nice you know who doesn't
want everybody to be to be looked after
and to have wise people making the kinds
of decisions but if that's just as far
as you've gone in your political
thinking then I would say don't yet vote
please study some history study some
politics study some economics and and
and and make sure you understand how you
our initial estimate will be going to
work out in practice that's a lot of
effort you know having to go to read
haven't you go and do research and learn
about economics is it's much easier for
me to just pick a side and start
mudslinging right yeah oh well for sure
so yeah but then what we I would then
say if you recognize that you're looking
for shortcuts and you're just
emotionally motional e interested in
attacking people on the internet well
you're not a serious person yet and
again please don't vote but you're right
it is a lot of work but that's you know
what this huge investment we have in
education we're basically in the rich
countries what we say to young people is
you know for 18 years we're going to
give you relatively an easy life we just
want you to go to school it'll clean up
your room once in a while playing sports
and take music lessons but in that 18
years pay attention you
history class pay attention in your
literature class and do some reading so
that by the time you are an adult you
you actually know something about the
world so that when you have the boat you
can exercise that vote responsibly the
problem and this is the same in every
election is that the vote of stupid or
purely passionate person is worth the
same as the vote of a person who is well
informed and has a concrete grounded
position yes
so one immediate response then is to say
that you know hopefully the vote of one
stupid informed person voting labour is
canceled out by the vote of one stupid
uninformed person voting for less excuse
me what right and and it does depending
on you know the passions of the moment
and and so forth and then also we do
know that there are a large number of
people who are of just apathetic about
politics and they don't vote and those
tend to be the more uninformed people so
you know they they self select out of
the process so I my view though is that
electoral politics matters but it is
more the vote of people who care about
politics and who are active and those
people tend to be more informed than the
average so you know democratic politics
for all of its weaknesses is is not that
bad and it certainly is better than the
alternatives historically yeah it sounds
to me like post-modernism is quite a
luxury position and given the fact that
we're currently in the middle of a
global pandemic what what does that mean
for post-modernism does it mean that
we're gonna see post-modernism receding
is it a luxury they can only be indulged
when times are good
yes now that's a very interesting
question because it is the case that
post-modernism has been initially a high
intellectual project coming out of
philosophy departments in the middle
part of the century and then extending
through higher education and much of
higher education now is a luxury good
consumed by relatively well-off people
in well-off countries so and a large
amount of it is is subsidized so that
does seem to be borne out that when you
go to the poorer nations of the world
they tend to be much more reality focus
they're aware of poverty they want their
lives to be improved and so when they
look around more likely to say you know
what are the policies economically and
the political systems that have
succeeded at putting food on the table
and the track record there again is that
it's been the individualistic free
market friendly liberal democratic
nations around the world that had been
successful so those models are much more
attractive post-modernism is less
attractive when I was a visiting
professor in Eastern Europe in Poland in
particular they had the experience of
socialism they knew what political
brutality is like they know what
socialism in practice means they're
looking at Western Europe they're
looking at North America where again
individualism liberal democracy being
Pro scientific have worked they're much
more attracted to that post-modernism
has much less traction there so I think
your hypothesis has a lot to it yeah I
get that so looping back now to
socialism and it's it's less than rosy
track record I know this is a complex
question that would require a lot of
different iterations to make it give it
an answer canned socialism work full
stop because it doesn't sound to me
based on the examples that you've given
the fully socialist society has a
tremendously long shelf
right so yeah the evidence if you want
to have a particularly a medium or large
size society the only way to do that is
through giving individuals lots of
freedom and then we're pretty good at
working out voluntary networks you know
large scale businesses large-scale
market stock markets bond markets to
move capital around and make investment
decisions and so on so those are very
effective at harnessing the intelligence
and the efforts of hundreds thousands or
millions of people and just at an
organizational level concentrating power
in the hands of the government and
leaving it up to a few dozens decisions
to be people to make decisions for all
of an economy that ends up always being
very bureaucratic very cumbersome and it
just sets itself up for an abuse of
power and you end up in a dictatorship
type of society but over and beyond all
of that just on moral grounds there is
something offensive about telling young
people that you cannot pursue your own
dream you can't make your own choices
about what your career is going to be
that we don't trust you enough to take
self responsibility for your own
economic lives to be your own
entrepreneur so on moral grounds I think
the liberal capitalist nations are far
superior because what they're saying to
individuals is look your life is yours
you should take responsibility for your
own life you're not a child anymore we
have confidence in you that you can make
an go of your own life and be your own
entrepreneur if you want to be an artist
you want to go and make beautiful cars
you want to be a an actor you want to
start whatever business it is go for it
that strikes me as a much more moral
approach to human living than saying you
know we all have to band together in a
group we don't think people can make it
on their own we need to have wise people
make decisions for you and make sure
that you're look after it's very
condescending
as well now all of that said I do I
don't want to say that socialism can't
work because there are small-scale
experiments and socialism that have
proved to be quite long-lived so for
example if you think about religious
communities there are lots of
monasteries and convents where you have
a small group of like-minded religious
people who all have the same goal they
all want to worship in the same way and
they will all live very socialistic aliy
everybody is sleeping in communal halls
eating and praying at the same time and
working together on all projects and it
seems to be the case that if your
community is no longer no larger than
say a hundred people or so where
everybody can keep track of everybody
that you can have a pretty long lived
socialistic community there are also
examples now multi-generational of
non-religious communities there are lots
of hippie communes or communists' people
in California or Oregon who say you know
we want to drop out of larger American
society you know somebody's got a couple
of hundred acres we're all going to live
on the farm we're all going to work
together on the farm and live and eat
and share families communally and again
as long as the commune doesn't get too
large those do seem to be able to - and
everybody's committed to the same goals
those do seem to be workable my only
question then is you know as a someone
who's liberal libertarian the way I am I
have no problem with people dropping out
of society and starting their own
communes as you know if they want to but
you know is that really your moral ideal
for how human beings want to live and if
you are a communalist you want to start
your religious commune or your hippie
commune are you respecting other
people's freedom not to have to join
your commune and if people do come join
your community out for the
do you give them the right to opt out
and go back and and pursue their own
dream in some other form so that's what
I would say to that
yeah it's people need to be liberal or
liberal enough to allow individuals and
groups to go and do that but also
liberal enough to accept the opinions of
the dissenters and/or the people who
want to exit and then leave or never
even enter in the first place there's a
lot of movie that's precisely what
strong socialists will say they will and
that's why they often want to go the
political group rather than starting a
voluntary commune they wanted to enact
socialism politically one day so once
it's enacted politically then you've got
the power of the police on your side and
you can make people follow your vision
so what happens where does the slippage
occur from going from because that
sounds you know they might not do it for
the rest of my life but if if you said
hey Chris there's ninety nine of the
people on this on this farm do you fancy
you know a couple of years just chilling
out and hoe in some ground and eating
some vegetables I'm like you know that
doesn't sound too bad but at some point
between that and a nation state there is
there's a problem is it that the total
cumulative amount of power is too easy
to wield in a way which is militarized
or sort of dictatorial yeah yeah one of
the problems is the problem of scale so
the small sales comp communes don't seem
to max out at about 150 because then
there's the question of the enforcement
mechanism you get say 100 let's keep the
numbers simple suppose you have one
hundred people and you might then say
you know I'm a voluntary person I'm
wanting people to opt in and out but
you're still going to have the issue
what happens if you you talk about the
issues you get together in your local
council and ninety-two of people agree
but eight people disagree what are you
going to do about the minority who
disagree in that case and in those cases
what seems to happen is most of the time
the eight people will with some you know
mild pressure put on them say okay I
will go along with it in this case but
once you get beyond 150 it's becomes
unwieldy to be having councils let's get
everybody together and talk over this
decision in that decision so you start
to have delegated groups delegated
committees who are then authorized to
make decisions in certain areas and they
then are a minority that has power over
the majority and then once they have
them mind power of the minority over the
majority they will start passing
legislation that will protect their
power increase their power and the
majority is increasingly not able to to
respond so once you then start to say
okay now we have 10,000 people you know
that might be a relatively small town
but there's no way you can get 10,000
people together on a regular basis to
discuss policy so necessarily you have a
town council of 10 or 20 people and they
have a lot of power and if and
eventually that power is necessarily
abused then when you start talking about
organizations that involve a million
people or ten million people it slips
into dictatorship pretty quickly it just
seemed like a very slippery slope the
the distribution of resources requires a
concentration of power in order to
determine how to distribute those
resources and because the distribution
of resources appears to be mostly
frictionless but yes the people who are
in power therefore have even fewer
barriers in order to be able to take
advantage of the situation is that right
that's exactly right I've got it Amiata
I understand yes and even if yeah even
if it's not the minority grabbing the
power and then turning it to of their
own purposes even to the extent that you
have a majority you might say okay now
we're still going to do it
democratically we have this small group
they're going to be able to make
proposals but every time it's a major
proposal we have to put it to the
electorate you're still going to have
the majority of people voting for
something and if you're in the minority
you're your rights and your individual
prerogatives can be suppressed so you
know you know what happens if we say you
know the majority of people are of one
ethnic group and they want to vote to
suppress the rights of a minority or the
majority happens to be women or males or
they're a racial group or they're a
religious group you still have the
suppression of minority interests that's
a that's a that's a chronic problem so
that's why they seriously liberal
individualistic societies have had
severe checks on the power of of society
they said you know we're going to
separate the legislative branch from the
executive branch from the judicial
branch so that no one part of the
government has too much power or we will
have explicitly constitutional
provisions things that we're just not
going to vote on we can't vote on
whether you are allowed to believe in
this God or not to believe in in in
God's at all religion is off-limits
individuals can do their their own
things if you decide that you're going
to be married with a woman or with a man
yeah we're not going to vote on who gets
to have sex with your husband or your
wife right that's your voluntary choice
right the democracy and the government
has no say in those sorts of things so
we explicitly take things off the table
to protect the individuals freedoms in
all those areas but socialist principles
in a that's our source approaches and
principles can't
do that because to the extent they say
that you as an individual belong to
society or you as an individual have to
be subordinated to social decisions and
all major decisions about the economy
about politics about religion about
science about sexuality should be social
well there are no protections for
individual freedom in the long run it
seems like there's been an awful lot of
work over the last let's say half
millennia on creating freedoms removing
barriers allowing people to have
sovereignty and creating a meritocracy
where people can vote with their actions
specifically obviously their money and
their votes literally yes that looking
at your feet yeah vote with their feet
whether they want to move this yeah she
especially in a country you know even
Canada it's so big it's so big just goes
somewhere else there's loads of
different places the UK if I Drive 300
miles in any direction from where I am
I'm in the water so I can't go quite so
far and we've now let the European Union
so I can't even I can't even go go to
Europe quite so easily but um yeah you
know this meritocracy thing the people
whose successes are theirs to bear great
the people whose failures are theirs to
bear also you know not not not so great
for them but hopefully if the system has
not enough not too much friction in it
everybody can reach the top or at least
start to move themselves up it that
seems you know on a fundamental level it
doesn't seem like that's an outrageous
proposition and it doesn't surprise me
that that's the most popular set up for
a nation at the moment yes yeah
absolutely
you know a lot of it depends on an
individual's you know self assessment
psychologically and we've been talking
about ethical principles and political
principles but you know there is a
difference also psychologically between
people who will look at a liberal
individualistic society
embrace it and they'll say that sounds
great I have all of this freedom I can
do whatever they want but it works with
their self-esteem and their sense that
they can make a go of it in their own
life but there also are individuals who
will be frightened by that degree of
self responsibility and freedom because
then they will say I don't know that I
am really that competent and you give me
all of these choices and say it's all up
to me
well what if I fail and they're afraid
of failure and they then more naturally
want to have someone look after them
they want a guaranteed insurance policy
so there also is a psychological element
that has to be attended to here yeah
suppose that's why you try and litigate
little successes for everybody
whilst mandating that no one can take
all of them I've got a yes I've got
quote from so your your book explaining
post-modernism you said that the failure
of socialism made post-modernism
necessary so that that suggests that if
socialism were to succeed post-modernism
would no longer be necessary we've got a
yeah an economy that all over the place
at the moment there's a populist
yearning for some form of socialism
right now so as socialism becomes more
prominent we'll post-modernism lose its
appeal and also I guess how do you see
their current global environment
relating to people's socialists desires
yeah yes what's a connecting
post-modernism to socialism to loop back
to where we began and thanks for the
plug of my book I proceeded and linked
in show notes below available on Amazon
and all good book suppliers of course
nice yes good so yeah that is a thesis
about how post-modernism arose so what
is interesting about the first
generation of all of the major post
modernists is that they all were far
left in their political orientation some
form of socialism and the problem was
from that perspective was that socialism
was becoming a
a stir in all of its major experiments
and also in terms of the just the
academic and intellectual arguments for
and against socialism so there the issue
then is you know what happens if you are
a true believer in a political ideology
but just all of the data and all of the
arguments seem to be going against you
what we do know that some people will be
open-minded and they will be
intellectually honest and they will say
okay you know I had this hypothesis I
had this theory and the arguments are
against it and the data are against it I
just have to reject my theory and change
my mind and try some other kind of
politics but we do know that there are
lots of people who will double down on a
theory that they know is failing and try
some intellectual machination z' in
order to save the theory in various ways
so if I can you know an analogy I like
to use in this is if we think about
religion you know there are lots of
people when they are young they're
raised in a given religious tradition
and they think it's beautiful and it's
true and it's noble and a big part of
their identity is tied up in believing
that that religion is true but then you
become older and you are aware that
there are lots of criticisms of your
religion and they seem like they're
pretty good criticisms and you study the
history of your religion you see that
people who are members of your religion
did all sorts of nasty things and and so
forth well what do you do well a lot of
people will change their mind about
their religion they will they will you
know not be religious anymore or they
will leave that religion and go looking
for for a better religion but we know
there are lots of people who will double
down on their religion and reaffirm
their commitment to religion and they
will resort to all sorts of you know
transparent sometimes but other kinds of
more sophisticated but nonetheless
dishonest strategies to try to deflect
any criticisms of their religion or they
just closed their mind and and double
down on their faith the same thing
happens in politics and for some sub
movements of socialism too in the latter
part of the twentieth century a
generation or so of
that's what happened and the post-modern
connection is is is quite clear
lots of people were attracted to
socialism but at the same time they
recognized the bad track record of
socialism and that the the the
prevailing strategies intellectual
strategies for socialism were not
working and post-modernism was an
attractive new strategy for them to to
adopt now that's the first half of your
question the second half of your
question was about the the current
global climate and there are people who
are not left politically are not
socialist politically who are also now
adopting some postmodern strategies so
you can see some people on the far right
also now catching up and using some
postmodern strategies so they will argue
you know this liberal individualism the
idea that everybody should be scientific
and rational and that we should have
maybe one open global economy were
opposed to that and instead they will
argue that we're not socialists but we
do believe in our ethnicity for example
I'm Hungarian or I am German
or I am you find these people in Britain
as well and as well as in America but
whether will do is they will say it's my
national identity and my ethnic and
identity that makes me what I am so
again it's not me as an individual
pursuing my dream but rather I'm born
into an ethnic group or a national group
and that has made me who I am
and my first loyalty should be to that
national group and if you were born in a
different ethnic group or a different
national group there's no way that you
and I can rationally discuss our
differences ultimately it's your group
versus my group and so they're arguing
for what kind of a nationalistic or an
ethnic collectivism and they're opposed
to you know this modern individualistic
free-market globalist society as they
put it as well but at the same time
they're not socialists so post-modernism
is having its inroads in other sectors
as well that's so interesting it's a
little bit like a Hydra it is yeah so
one of the things again my particular
interest is more in the way that
individuals operate and as you're
talking and explaining I'm genuinely
just learning along here as I'm sure
that a lot of the audience are as well
kind of treading on fresh ground here
and learning about these new areas at
different ways of political thought
philosophical thought I'm relating this
to the way that I understand people to
operate right so I know and everyone
that's listening has had a discussion
with someone it might be their partner
might be that their friend might just be
a person on the street but probably
definitely someone on the internet where
you know they're wrong they might
actually kind of know that they're wrong
as well and you say hey you're wrong
Steven you don't know what you're
talking about
or you do know what you're talking about
but you're still wrong and yet those
people decide to double down they dig
their heels in further they decide to
push their position even harder and it
increases how militantly they believe in
what they're doing now yes when we're
talking about I think Iron Man's better
than the Hulk and you actually think
that the Hulk's better than Iron Man or
Thor's better or Wonder Woman or
whatever um that's fine I I feel like
when people are talking this vehement
Lee and allowing cognitive biases that
really you should have overcome with a
bit of a bit of life experience some
learning and a couple of hundred hours
of mindfulness practice when you have
people who are able to create entire
intellectual and political arenas of
thought which have effects for
generations there
after they can not be killed
is there not a way that we can protect
ourselves that we shouldn't be allow
people shouldn't be able to have wield
so much power it's like it's like giving
a child a nuclear bomb you know it's
like this the individual that is
wielding this incredibly powerful weapon
actually doesn't have a clue what
they're doing and is completely at the
mercy of all of the same idiotic primal
responses that me and you have and
everyone that's listening mm-hmm no I
think that's that's right as perceptive
and it's well stated about a fundamental
problem that we have and I'm somewhat
optimistic I think we're doing better in
the early 21st century then people did
in previous centuries but it still is
easy to be dismayed when we're on the
Internet and we realize still how
widespread the problems are and it
really does come down to an individual
moral choice that each of us has to make
for ourselves you know am i no matter
what I want to believe am i really
paying attention to the evidence doing
my best to follow trains of logic
particularly on things that I know are
complicated and that I've not
necessarily studied for a great deal of
time am I willing to say I made a
mistake and that's that's hard for
everybody to do but if you were
intellectually honest you know some
things you've not thought a lot about
you know some things are complicated you
know that along the way when you were
younger you probably picked up lots of
beliefs semi consciously are you willing
to re-examine those beliefs and say I
made a mistake yes or no am I willing to
change my mind and then even more
difficulty am I willing to do that
publicly so
you know if I go on the internet and I'm
having a discussion
I really would urge many people to try
this as an actual experiment get into a
discussion about something and make a
point to say you are right and I am
wrong about something you're getting to
get to it into an issue where you know
someone is smart and knows more than you
do
and open yourself up to that it can be
very cathartic to publicly admit that
you have made a mistake but you know on
some issue and if you're not willing to
go that that route then you do need to
do some self-examination I absolutely
love that as an experiment it's add add
a Dave Rubin from Rubin report on last
night talking about I've been very
similar very very similar topics and I
said exactly the same Eckhart Tolle a
saison in one of his books that the
reason that we fear being proved wrong
in an argument is because it is
tantamount to the destruction of our ego
and that sense that dread it's like
standing on the edge of a cliff you know
and you look it over and you can feel it
rises inside of you you feel it in sort
of moves up from your stomach up into
your chest and again you get all hot and
you your shoulders start to come up and
you start to hear that's like tinnitus
sound in your ears all you know
everybody that's listening is experience
this oh anger and it's rage and it you
like just it's fine
it is yeah absolutely fine yeah that's
that's nicely put there is an ego issue
there the way I like to phrase it though
is to say that I you you need to
recognize when that is going on that you
have a weak or developing ego because
the the calmness that you end up with
the way you nicely put it just a few
seconds ago that is the sign of strength
to be able to say I recognize that I am
NOT an omniscient being
and that making mistakes along the way
is a normal part of the process and if I
am strong-minded enough to say what
really matters to me is the truth then
the strongest person is the person who
says I have made mistakes along the way
and that I'm not going to think less of
myself because I because I did so it's
the same by analogy to physical
development mental development and
physical development are perfectly
parallel on this point if you are going
to become good at any physical activity
a sport and so forth
you have are going to make a huge number
of mistakes along the way you're gonna
fall down sprained ankles stub your toes
get dirt on your face and so forth and
to be able to to recognize that you
screwed up you hit the ball out of
bounds someone scored a goal on you and
they made a good shot and you screwed up
being able to admit that and learn from
those mistakes that's the sign of a
strong person it's the it's the weak
person who says yes I'm 14 years old and
I'm the best tennis player in the world
well sorry that's childish yeah I am I
wouldn't know how much different the
world could have been if some
intellectuals over the last century or
two had been able to admit that they
were wrong yeah so it's a particular
occupational hazard for intellectuals
because you know we all like to think of
ourselves as smarter than the average
person and our whole career is based on
credentials and and being smart so
admitting that you are wrong is is a
higher stakes enterprise but at the same
time there are lots of intellectuals in
history you know from Socrates to
Bertrand Russell and a large part of
their reputation has precisely been
based on being able to say you know I
don't know right or yeah I thought that
was right but I made a mistake and I
changed my mind and here's my new and
improved theory so so so be
strong-minded hey if Bertrand Russell
can do it there
there's you know the rest the rest of us
can as well look Steven I've I've
genuinely learned an absolute ton this
evening so thank you so much for coming
on your books liberalism pro and con
that's the new one you got a couple of
those tell us tell us what liberalism
and why is it pro and con and not pros
and cons yes well it's a little bit
generic the book is a is a primer that
then is to say I don't take a position
in that book except for a methodological
position and that is then to say if
we're going to think about liberalism
socialism conservatism libertarianism or
whatever the first thing we need to do
is to recognize these are complex issues
and there's lots of smart and
well-meaning people who develop lots of
really good arguments so what I've done
is identified 15 most prominent powerful
arguments for liberalism and presented
them in the book but at the same time 15
powerful anti liberal arguments in the
book and given lots of quotations from
the major protagonists and from
historical times in contemporary times
so my marketing pitch for the book is
before you make up your mind about
anything in politics these are the
thirty arguments pro and con that you
need to know and if you don't know those
arguments yet you still have some some
homework to do so hopefully it should be
some fun homework but nonetheless this
is what you need to study to get up to
speed and by reading those thirty
arguments then you know marks you know
Aristotle you know Nietzsche you know
Heidegger you know all of the big names
and the arguments then you're in a
position to make up your own mind where
your political views stand whether
you're more Pro liberal or anti liberal
I love that I think that's really really
good and what did we save you know
looping it right back to the very
beginning people need to be educated
this is the sort of thing that people
should be learning in school so maybe
you're the the surrogate
teacher that we never had Stephen well
thanks for that yeah I am a philosophy
professor so I think a lot about my
students and how to get them up the
learning curve and yeah this book is is
of that project it's directed primarily
to no thoughtful thinking people of any
age but especially for university level
students who are taking their first
serious steps into thinking about
politics economics and philosophy
amazing well it will be linked in the
show notes below along with explaining
post-modernism and Stephens fantastic
Twitter Stephen man I'm gonna have to
find another reason to get you back on
hopefully not a global panda hat but we
will work it out yes for sure Chris
great questions enjoyed enjoyed your
your tone of voice your your benevolent
spirit and thanks for having me God
thank you so much Stephen I'll catch you
later on all right bye for now
[Music]